so much of our information is digital
right now that if the power went out we
would instantly lose access to
all of these databases oh yeah oh yeah
yeah like it's so fragile you had a
bookshelf power went out yet books
there was a funny meme where some guy
was like the future is lame my book just
ran out of batteries yeah exactly like i
was on a plane in my book ran out of
batteries what am i supposed to do
yup i mean that's the end of
space balls right even in the future
nothing works yeah that's the line when
the the self-destruct cancellation
button doesn't work it's convenient that
my phone grants me the summation uh
grants me access to the summation of
human knowledge but uh when the battery
dies i got a brick actually have you
heard about this idea that we're going
to enter a new
historically speaking not for us in the
moment we're not going to live through a
dark age but historically speaking this
is going to be a huge dark age because
everything's digital right so if you the
thing i saw about it was like well if
you write on a clay tablet right if you
scratch or you know kinetic form or
whatever it is on a clay tablet 5000
years later if it didn't break you can
still read it right
well if you put something on like a dvd
which is
far better storage than
say a thumb drive which if like two
drops of water hit it all your data's
gone you put something on like a
physical medium like a dvd
you got 10 to 12 15 years before that
thing can degrade enough unless it's one
of those really really expensive ones
that most people don't use yeah so
what's gonna happen is we have all these
records like you know your wikipedia
entry which we
my wikipedia entry which is which is lit
they're all just ephemeral is it wrong
well
sometimes it changes a lot um i think
it's a little bit wrong
at one point though
somebody added that i have gigantic
balls made of brass
and that was a sentence on my wikipedia
for about like four days but it's wrong
because it's titanium that's right yeah
the gigantic part is correct the metal
part is correct they got the metal all
wrong grass is too soft that's right and
it turns things green yeah right i
thought i was on this i thought i was
right no but i was talking about this
the other day that um
if we got hit by that solar flare that
they've been talking about well we
almost did
well you'd walk into uh
people would like wearing their uh you
know leathers with spears and paint
under their faces they'd walk into a
manhattan data center and be like kids
look
knowledge
it could teach us how to find food
how to generate electricity but we have
no idea how to access any of it yeah so
it's gone we almost did i don't know if
you knew that it was like 2004 or five
we'd have to look up the date there was
like the the solar flail flare that
would have destroyed yeah a big big cme
that would have been like
it for our entire grid right and the way
you know everything's spinning the sun's
spinning the earth is moving it missed
by like
if the sun had blown up like 16 hours
earlier it would have been a direct hit
and fried earth wow and that's how much
it missed by and it you know it went off
into space beside the earth the earth
just barely missed it but you know the
us government's got deep underground
bunkers with faraday cage under faraday
cage and protection from nuclear blasts
and all that stuff yeah all your nudes
are definitely in those bunkers that
google's been storing up you think i'm
joking have you have you played the game
fallout 3 no
uh you'd love it um
fallout 3 is one of the best in the
fallout series but it's a
post-apocalyptic and you're in
washington dc like a nuclear war
happened and now there's mutants and you
know ghouls they're like people with
like radiation sickness and stuff and uh
it's it's a it's a real map of dc it's
amazing but there's uh the bad guys or
an element of what you described as bad
guys the enclave remnants of the us
government who have technology because
they were in bunkers and then there's
other people with technology too but
they're like you know the remnants of
the us government so if there was to be
a major emp nuclear war or some kind of
apocalypse whatever
the governments of the world are
will survive it yeah the shadow
government i asked alex jones what's the
difference between the deep state of the
shadow government a couple years ago
before i learned more about the
administrative state actually being the
deep state he was like the shadow
governments in case there's a nuclear
war
they're all they're all ready for it
that was a good impression it wasn't too
bad
yeah you got down there you got deep oh
thanks yeah that was pretty good deep in
the kind of gravelly yeah a little
gravely really real serious real serious
yeah i mean well the next i'll tell you
well the hard drives we're evolving to
do hard drives made out of glass so if
there's an emp you'll still be able to
hit with a laser and read the data and
also d um dna they're storing data and
dna that's terrifying so i there there
have like been weird conspiracies about
quartz crystals data storage or energy
storage and stuff like that
and
it's it's entirely possible that there
exists
maybe maybe you're a fan of ancient
aliens or whatever it's possible i'm not
saying it's likely or even remotely
likely but there could be ancient data
storage tech that we just assume is a
rock and we would never know if if you
if you gave a hard drive to you know an
amazon amazon tribe with like no contact
with other civilization they wouldn't
know what it was
you could you couldn't even explain to
them how the information is on there no
not even close
i like the idea that in the future men
are proposing with like rings that
actually store all of the most important
data that they have and then they have
to trust that this woman is not going to
lose it like that's how bond stronger
bonded marriage has to be i think i
think where we're headed is that the
woke people are going to line up for
neurolink and enter the metaverse and
that's where they're going to be and if
they're they're going to drag everybody
else in that i mean that's i think the
attempt that there's actually a policy
document from the world economic forum
it's their vision 2025 document that i
read the other day i read such fun
things
and uh i'm reading through all of these
you know different visions and like
education and technology and all of this
and then i'm starting to read like
comparing against some of the different
articles they put out that they cite and
there's this article that they put out
that said that edtech has failed
them their their vision like they they
wrote all this stuff back in like 16
about how important it was for edtech to
rise up and do social emotional learning
and literally like read kids emotions
with like heart monitors and eye
tracking and like all this crazy stuff
that's happening by the way in florida
they're actually doing an experiment in
some counties with what they call heart
math so while you do your math lesson
you're strapped into a heart rate
monitor to find out what stresses you're
out about the math lesson like i don't
want any company having that data by the
way but um
i'm reading this thing and it's like
well what we're learning is that you can
bring education into the metaverse but
not the other way around and so the goal
will be that school is in the metaverse
like if you want your kid to go to
school they're gonna have to slap on a
facebook owned oculus and go into the
metaverse and you know who knows what's
going on in there and
you think you're gonna be able to look
over your kid's shoulder and see what's
happening on the ipad no it's gonna be
in the metaverse they're talking about
digital travel in that document you know
so nobody's going anywhere you're only
you the plebs have to go to meta room
only the real rich and famous can go to
rome uh for real for example and so
they're actually talking about this
though the travel industries way deep
into virtual travel could you imagine
like signing up for a cruise and really
do is put you in like a a classroom with
like a drop ceiling and then you put
your goggles on and you pretend you're
at this at sea like yeah you ever seen
those they have these things you can buy
where it's like a body harness and
you're standing on a bowl and you put on
special shoes and you can actually walk
by like the shoes are touch sensitive or
whatever so when you walk you're
actually walking in the metaverse
i was at um
i was at vidcon years ago six years ago
and they had a big display where there
were two guys up on these things
strapped in and they're running full
speed but they're strapped in a body
harness and you could watch what they
see and they were playing a first person
shooter against haptic vests and stuff
so you can feel yourself getting haptic
hands and stuff um right now i think the
biggest advancements they've made is
they have a lot of different tech that
doesn't really work together very well
to provide a
mostly immersive experience but that
will be a big part of it yeah they talk
about virtual reality and education but
they also like there's another document
this this paper called psycho data put
out by by actually a critical theorist
by the name of ben williamson uh 2019 in
the journal of education policy and he's
talking about that the actual point of
all this is to harvest the data that's
the real point and that what what he
argued he's like why are they harvesting
the data well number one they want to
create perfectly forecastable economic
conditions in people so they want to
make you perfect for the market so they
can predict exactly how much money
you'll spend and when and then condition
you to make sure that you meet your
predictions and then secondly is to
control populations
so the what it is is a gigantic data
harvesting program to make you think
you're playing a video game or sending
your kids to school
and you know right now they're surveying
the kids primarily they have to fill out
these surveys all the time i just like
school just started back so all these
parents are like screenshotting them and
sending them to me
on on social media that's not twitter
and they are it's kind of like freaky
the things they're asking these kids
it's like have you you know do you ever
think about racist stuff you know it's
like crazy how often do you think about
suicide they're asking kids questions
like that wow yeah it's intense and then
you know how much money do your parents
make there's all these crazy intense
survey questions they're asking these
kids all the time as a result
of the implementation of social
emotional learning it's almost like
aliens are here you know in secret and
they're collecting data and like
researching us i'm saying almost like
i'm saying it's true i'm just saying
that it feels that way it feels like
we're being we're like chickens in a
chicken coop well i mean so my guess is
is if we are looking at kind of a
revolutionary moment is that what if i
were if i were a communist and i were
looking at the situation i would say
well in the past we've attempted to
build out
the uh the society right the the economy
that was the soviet union we built the
economy and tried to force people to
live in it it was a catastrophe and then
in china we built the people we built
all the revolutionaries and then this
hasn't worked out the way we wanted it
to either what do you have to do you
have to build them both at the same time
so you start harvesting the data while
you program the kids and the school and
then you're building the society based
on the data you're harvesting from the
kids the economy the completely
controlled and conditioned economy and
then smack when the metaverse is ready
everybody's pushed into the perfect uh
the perfect simulation economy will you
control what people can see and hear and
say and you'll control what their
reality is people don't know what they
don't know that's right i would do a
digital tour of one of the great
pyramids of egypt you can go inside and
go down frame by frame and look around
and look at the walls and like i really
feel like i was there sometimes i'm like
i was i i forget that i wasn't in egypt
when i it was immensely awesome yeah so
i mean that's immensely awesome but then
imagine what they could do with that
first of all how do you even how would
you even know if it's really the real
thing right so what if you had gone down
like halfway down the thing you probably
would have been like wait a minute if
somebody had like spray painted a giant
penis on the wall or something like that
but they could insert that in or it
could really be there and then they've
deleted it and you don't know but then
everybody you know we always talk about
the sell the dream side of this wow you
know i had this experience i was in
egypt i got to experience what it's like
to win the super bowl kind of first hand
i get to be on the field i was tom brady
it was so amazing they don't ever tell
you that they could also just import you
into like a torture prison yep they
don't ever tell you that part there's a
movie we've talked about before where
it's like this
they invent this thing they put in your
eye and it gives you experiences
so this woman she like drops it like
nanobots go into your brain and then she
experiences a weekend and aspen and
she's skiing and snowboarding and then
her partner against her wishes makes
prison nanites so like you put in
someone's eye and they experience 100
years in jail yeah that's what i'm
saying five minutes later they wake up
like all messed up yeah totally messed
up like i read this book it's called
thought reform in the psychology of
totalism by robert j lifton and he was
br he was in hong kong in the 1950s he
published in 1961 and what he's doing is
he's actually interviewing uh people as
they got out of mao's prisons in the in
the 50s
like literally like a week after they
get out of three years in a maoist
communist prison and he's interviewing
these people and he says that literally
zero people people were affected
differently by their three to five years
in prison in the chinese thought reform
prisons or brainwashing prisons she now
in chinese as they call him and
but everybody was affected everybody
came out completely as i mean imagine of
course you would but as a completely
different person um and you could do
that digitally we could we don't need
gulags if you have
digital experience gulags and you can't
leave your house because you know you
don't have enough credits like in
australia when they did the covet and if
you left your house like a freaking
drone is following your car or something
you know there's
this isn't
just like hyperbole anymore you're
familiar with the uh
the rat experiment which one the the
hope hope experiment no well maybe took
three cylinders put rats in each one let
them swim until they got tired but
within about 15 minutes the rats gave up
sand to the bottom and died oh yeah then
he took another rats he put him in
once they right when they gave up he
grabbed them took them out dried them
off and let them rest
then picked them back up put them in the
second time around they swam for 60
hours because there was hope they
believed that if they just stuck to it
they would eventually be saved and they
shouldn't give up
and so some have made the argument
following the pandemic and all the
insane things they did
we are still in it we're just in the
hope portion and this explains why they
built permanent facilities in say
australia and other places australia's
got this this uh this the howard springs
i think it's called we actually had the
we showed you the shirt earlier when
you're when you're over here they they
built permanent facilities it was for
what six months well it was it existed
before it was um uh it was my place for
mining right but i mean like
the the the work that they did
organizing these facilities and setting
them up i don't think was just for six
months yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you